what i'm about to share with you our
findings from a study of the brains of
more than one thousand children and
adolescents
now these were children who were
recruited from diverse homes around the
united states and this picture is an
average of all of their brains
the front of this average brain is on
your left and the back of this average
brain is on your right
now one of the things we were very
interested in was the surface area of
the cerebral cortex or the thin wrinkly
layer on the outer surface of the brain
that does most of the cognitive heavy
lifting
and that's because past work by other
scientists has suggested that in many
cases a larger cortical surface area is
often associated with higher
intelligence
now in this study
we found one factor that was associated
with the cortical surface area across
nearly the entire surface of the brain
that factor
was family income
now here every point you see in color is
a point where higher family income was
associated with a larger cortical
surface area in that spot
and there were some regions shown here
in yellow where that association was
particularly pronounced
and those are regions that we know
support a certain set of cognitive
skills
language skills like vocabulary and
reading
as well as the ability to avoid
distraction and exert self-control
and that's important because those are
the very skills that children living in
poverty are most likely to struggle with
in fact a child living with poverty is
likely to perform worse on tests of
language and impulse control
before they even turn two
now
there are a few points i'd like to
highlight about this study number one
this link between family income and
children's brain structure was strongest
at the lowest income levels
so that means that dollar for dollar
relatively small differences in family
income were associated with
proportionately greater differences in
brain structure among the most
disadvantaged families and intuitively
that makes sense right an extra twenty
thousand dollars for a family earning
say a hundred fifty thousand dollars a
year would certainly be nice but
probably not game changing
whereas an extra twenty thousand dollars
for a family only earning twenty
thousand dollars a year would likely
make a remarkable difference in their
day-to-day lives
now the second point i'd like to
highlight is that this link between
family income and children's brain
structure didn't depend on the
children's age
it didn't depend on their sex and it
didn't depend on their race or ethnicity
and the final point and this one's key
there was tremendous variability from
one child to the next
by which i mean there were plenty of
children from higher income homes with
smaller brain surfaces
and plenty of children from lower income
homes with larger brain surfaces
here's an analogy we all know that in
childhood boys tend to be taller than
girls
but go into any elementary school
classroom and you'll find some girls who
are taller than some boys
so while growing up in poverty is
certainly a risk factor for a smaller
brain service in no way can i know an
individual child's family income and
know with any accuracy with that
particular child's brain would look like
i want you to imagine for a moment two
children one is a young child born into
poverty in america the other is also an
american child
but one who was born into more fortunate
circumstances
now at birth we find absolutely no
differences in how their brains work
but by the time those two kids are ready
to start kindergarten we know that the
child living in poverty is likely to
have cognitive scores that are on
average 60 percent lower than those of
the other child
later on that child living in poverty
will be five times more likely to drop
out of high school
and if she does graduate high school
she'll be less likely to earn a college
degree
by the time those two kids are 35 years
old
if the first child spent her entire
childhood living in poverty
she is up to 75 times more likely to be
poor herself
but it doesn't have to be that way
as a neuroscientist one of the things i
find most exciting about the human brain
is that our experiences
change our brains
now this concept known as
neuroplasticity
means that these differences in
children's brain structure don't doom a
child to a life of low achievement
the brain
is not destiny
and if a child's brain can be changed
then anything is possible
now
as a society we spend billions of
dollars each year educating our children
so what can we tell schools teachers and
parents who want to help support kids
from disadvantaged backgrounds to do
their best in school and in life
well emerging science suggests that
growing up in poverty is associated with
a host of different experiences and that
these experiences in turn may work
together to help shape brain development
and ultimately how kids learn
and so if this is right it begs the
question as to where along this pathway
can we step in and provide help
so let's consider first intervening at
the level of learning itself most
commonly through school-based
initiatives
now should we be encouraging teachers to
focus on the kinds of skills that
disadvantaged kids are most likely to
struggle with
of course
the importance of high quality education
based in scientific evidence really
can't be overstated
and there are a number of examples of
excellent interventions targeting things
like literacy or self-regulation that do
in fact improve kids cognitive
development and their test scores
but as any intervention scientist doing
this work would tell you this work is
challenging it's hard to implement high
quality evidence-based education and it
can be labor intensive it's sometimes
costly
and in many cases these disparities in
child development emerge early well
before the start of formal schooling
sometimes when kids are just toddlers
and so i would argue school is very
important but if we're focusing all of
our policy efforts on formal schooling
we're probably starting too late
so what about taking a step back and
focusing on trying to change children's
experiences
what particular experiences are
associated with growing up in poverty
and might be able to be targeted to
promote brain development and learning
outcomes for kids
well of course there are many right
nutrition
access to health care
exposure to secondhand smoke or lead
experience of stress or discrimination
to name a few
in my laboratory we're particularly
focused on a few types of experiences
that we believe may be able to be
targeted to promote children's brain
development and ultimately improve their
learning outcomes
as one example take something i'll call
the home language environment
by which i mean
we know that the number of words kids
hear and the number of conversations
they're engaged in every day can vary
tremendously
by some estimates kids from more
advantaged backgrounds hear an average
of 30 million more spoken words in the
first few years of life compared to kids
from less advantaged backgrounds
now in our work we're finding that kids
who experience more back and forth
responsive conversational turns
tend to have a larger brain surface in
parts of the brain that we know are
responsible for language and reading
skills
and in fact the number of conversations
they hear seems to matter a little bit
more than the sheer number of words they
hear
so one tantalizing possibility is that
we should be teaching parents not just
to talk a lot but to actually have more
conversations with their children
in this way it's possible that we'll
promote brain development and perhaps
their kids language and reading skills
and in fact a number of scientists are
testing that exciting possibility right
now
but of course we all know that growing
up in poverty is associated with lots of
different experiences beyond just how
many conversations kids are having
so how do we choose what else to focus
on the
list can be overwhelming
now there are a number of high quality
interventions that do try to change
children's experience many of which are
quite effective
but again just like school-based
initiatives this is hard work can be
challenging it can be labor-intensive
sometimes costly
and on occasion it can be somewhat
patronizing for scientists to swoop in
and tell a family what they need to
change in order for their child to
succeed
so
i want to share an idea with you
what if we tried to help young children
in poverty by simply giving their
families more money
i'm privileged to be working with a team
of economists social policy experts and
neuroscientists in leading babies first
years the first ever randomized study to
test whether poverty reduction causes
changes in children's brain development
now the ambition of this study is large
but the premise is actually quite simple
in may of 2018 we began recruiting 1 000
mothers living below the federal poverty
line shortly after they gave birth in a
number of american hospitals
now upon enrolling in our study all
mothers receive an unconditional monthly
cash gift for the first 40 months of
their children's lives
and they're free to use this money
however they like
but importantly mothers are being
randomized
so some mothers are randomized to
receive a nominal monthly cash gift
and others are randomized to receive
several hundred dollars each month an
amount that we believe is large enough
to make a difference in their day-to-day
lives in most cases increasing their
monthly income by 20 to 25 percent
so in this way
we're hoping to finally move past
questions of how poverty is correlated
with child development
and actually be able to test whether
reducing poverty causes changes in
children's cognitive emotional and brain
development in the first three years of
life
the very time when we believe the
developing brain may be most malleable
to experience
now
we won't have definitive results from
this study for several years and if
nothing else a thousand newborns and
their moms will have a bit more cash
each month that they tell us they very
much need
but what if it turns out that a
cost-effective way
to help young children in poverty
is to simply give their moms more money
if our hypotheses are borne out it's our
hope that results from this work will
inform debates about social services
that have the potential to affect
millions of families with young children
because while income may not be the only
or even the most important factor in
determining children's brain development
it may be one that from a policy
perspective can be easily addressed
put simply
if we can show that reducing poverty
changes how children's brains develop
and that leads to meaningful policy
changes
then a young child born into poverty
today
may have a much better shot
at a brighter future
thank you
[Music]
you